what's going on peach frontage accents
Greg outta here and it's John over
Hughes so we're going to do movie news
of the week today the top stories of the
week only got four here that actually
caught my interest and it's not really
much this week to be honest nothing none
of these are that too exciting and then
got a slow week everyone to one slow
week every once in a while you know III
is coming out so yes I don't want to
avail too much movie news and hellos
video games
swooping in oh yeah I'm the Thunder away
I passion right yeah yeah yeah okay for
all those trailer requests to come in
for that one no it's on witness all
right so let's just hop right into this
Suicide Squad - you bet you guys didn't
expect this needs to come out of the
game
you know DCU has a lot of film slated
not many released they throw many of
them - but here we go Joel Kinnaman the
main star of Suicide Squad - the one
that everyone remembers that even if you
don't know the comics we've seen the
movie you at least know his name know
Joel and I know his character's name
Rick Flagg Wow that's the one he's a
standout performance he says and some
interview as far as I know they're
writing the script and I think the plan
is to shoot at sometime in 2018 that
could change
I think I'll definitely come back for it
ultimately I'd love for David Ayer to
direct it but if he doesn't want to
direct it then someone who is great with
character that's able to ground the
story and maybe put these characters in
a more normal situation pretty much
saying whatever David Ayer said be
really interesting to see this crazy
characters interact with regular people
as well boy wouldn't that have been a
great idea mass suicide squad one yeah
learn from our mistakes why don't we
head I don't they did inspiring
information though because it's June now
they'll at least have six months to
address opposed to six weeks so they got
plenty of time
didn't get the script in development I I
mean we've talked a lot about other
potentials for Suicide Squad too on this
channel and the many different ways you
could do it the main thing is what he's
saying right here just make it a more
normal situation that yeah I don't have
to save the world they don't need to do
that doesn't make it a more normal
situation and I don't know I'm not
really excited that Joakim is talking
about that song yeah Gammage it about
your caricature to this movie
I'm not particularly excited either I
don't know I feel like the one kind of
nice ish thing that we've learned from
DC is uh you know these these ships can
correct their courses so while I'm not
overly optimistic for a suicide - let's
choose my squad - all night champing at
the bit to get these carry on back in a
room together I'm like I think they
could fix it and I like that there at
least planning to go ahead instead of
doing the spider-man thing just
restarting a game every time you fall
off that skateboard I made a reboot they
made it like so much freaking money yeah
yeah and I'm glad that they're not going
to do that long as it makes Bank you got
a sequel in mind it's just out in
studios worried if it makes money and
that's what they care about
we're quickly and uh yeah Mike's making
sure that Mike was on are you moving
forward to the next door we got more to
talk about about Suicide Squad yeah
because I'm wondering oh you know with a
lot of times when one movie works like
Wonder Woman really worked
haha Wonder Woman really worked itself
Wonder Woman worked
that means there's someone at the studio
there's at least one person or they're
going when we got to do all of our
future installments now just like just
like Wonder Woman ruin it that Suicide
Squad back to World War one yeah they're
going to do something someone there
who's going to say that this is someone
that but I got what I like of the idea
of a Suicide Squad - because I mean when
you see like the Marvel franchise going
it's like the we see a trait we saw
guardians to this year who saw the
trailers of Thor Ragnarok and black
panther
and there's something that seems kind of
similar about the way all of them are
and I don't feel like you need to do
that with the DCE UI I don't feel like
it needed uh fall under that category
especially with Suicide Squad out of all
having if you start doing that with all
your heroes in your solo thumbs maybe I
could I can get more onboard with that
however when it comes to Suicide Squad
now just make it different I mean that's
one thing you got to give credit to for
the first one is different
yeah a little bit weird that's part of
the charm and I and I think especially
for DC it would help them all the more
to differentiate I'll have this
franchise that's free to be the point of
suicides wanted to be edgy yet because
they want to shoot this in 2018 I'm
saying is whoever that one person is a
we got to make it like Wonder Woman um I
don't think you got to do that you can
still make it a good movie and make it
different than when a woman decides what
to zahl about love it yeah how about
heroism
yeah I'm really struggling it was me
fighting for the people right hey hey
let's move on to the next story
speaking of sequels my darling guess
what the dark universe they got a whole
bunch of unplanned yeah I love when they
throw a franchise in a high-speed I love
when they get off to a shaky start
they're like don't work it we're not
stopping there we got five more of these
up our sleeves yeah alex kurtzman we
lose what he said speaking of fandom we
know we're going to do frankenstein
Bride of Frankenstein Dracula Creature
from the Black Lagoon Phantom of the
Opera The Hunchback of Notre Dom and The
Invisible Man
Wow and I hope Russell Crowe is in all
of oh hey plays that for did you yeah
let's hope that that stays consistent
that was the best thing about we just
put up our review for The Mummy
non-spoiler and spoiler review you could
catch our thoughts on that oh boy
a lot of movies
it's a lot of work you can address this
in the film review for the new film of
The Mummy out in theaters now and um I I
don't think this machine cannot be
corrected in any way you know like I
said we're talking about suicides
Suicide Squad just now I believe that
you can take feedback and make some
positive change however I really wish
these people could focus on one movie
well Chris Morgan is one of the you know
main people guiding that the guiding
forces are Alex Kurtzman and Chris
Morgan and Chris Morgan while he did the
fourth Fast and Furious he's not all the
other Fast and Furious --iz and he
helped he was greatly involved in course
correction for the Fast & Furious
franchise you know and I'm not sure if
he's still the right guy he did I think
the course correcting for that series
will work for him yeah
but sure it is good knows maybe maybe it
will I'm not gonna say that that guy's
only capable idea yeah in my work who
knows and I just hope that Alex Kurtzman
Inca like I'm sure they have a lot of
plans already I'm sure they got a lot of
notes written down of what they want to
do because they already started casting
people for all these roles I just really
hope that they go where do we slow down
a little bit and maybe you know rethink
how we did the mummy cuz now you're
better than what it was announced yeah
Creature from the Black Lagoon which was
hinted at in the movie movie and that's
a neat hit because because one humps oh
yeah yeah when in a spoiler alert for
the mummy for your black lagoon tease
when they're walking through um what's
it called
please vagina vagina they're walking
through shield
and you see the lagoon hand yeah and
then everyone everyone being you and me
these are the blog reader
why are we the only people excited sees
that mother but it was already in like a
a specimen jar severed impact why oh the
creature right is so if they do a
Creature from the Black Lagoon it might
be a film that takes place before
present day which could be cool or he'll
have a hook hand or I'll have a book and
it's about I'm kind of retreated to God
my hands movie Matt magic hands source
of all my powers and they got other
characters here phantom hunchback who
are not part of the og month servers
right those you want the wrong Frank
wolf dreck
I mean missing someone bride brothers
herbal man I mean yeah I feel like the
originals are sort of like yeah Freya
and the mummy and the Wolfman and and
then you branch out you've got the
creature in the mummy and I say whatever
it doesn't matter
yeah doesn't matter fat man how much bag
art are monsters but they're not part of
the og I mean they are they made those
movies they made the canonical with with
launching a like original crossovers I
could oh yeah they're all Universal
monster movies I don't know who if they
ever crossed over with anybody yeah we
should have just called this the
universal monster no need to call it the
dark universe because I think you're not
honoring dark and in this whole thing
image it you got going on here yeah I'm
completely about cause it's like now I'm
like I'm kind of cool that they didn't
call it the Universal Monsters because
what I saw yesterday wasn't really a
universal monster movie at least
completely yeah I'm sure that looks like
the dark universe I guess but I just
think this would be cooler period piece
films definitely modern David yes in
Italy it's like if you do a modern-day
at Hunchback of Notre Dom what the hell
is that gonna be y-yeah yeah or a
modern-day phantom we'll be reviewing a
traitor's justice off friends [ __ ] we
don't treat hunchback like that today is
be a major issue
like this is guys you don't live in the
top of the bell tower to like you know
everybody noticed because I now know how
many cameras inside that church in a
modern world yeah I don't know what
they're doing
let's just hope that they make some
course correction immediately his boy do
they need it because you know like when
you look at other franchises that's
universes that have been launched
officially you know Godzilla was great
he did with the Daisy Gareth Evans he
did what Alex Kurtzman cell he was going
to Edward Edwards right Evans is Rick
yeah he did what Alex Kurtzman said he
would do for the money and he made a
great so little film that had no concern
with universe building that was cool and
then DC you launched it with Man of
Steel and while it wasn't the greatest
thing on the planet it was so good
enough to be like damn abort watch no
more watch more DC yeah I'm totally here
for that kind of a different take this
is the first franchise universe launch
where I'm like very worried worried I
don't know how much more of these I can
handle it all gonna be like this you do
understand that these are like your
flagship classics right do you
understand the implications of that like
um yeah I kind of pretty much agree with
everything you just said like I don't
really see what breathe like bringing
these things to modern day where we've
got computers and cell phones and crazy
advanced guns and things like I didn't I
don't see I think that much back should
be all CGI and it's like he should be a
giant with an intentionally big
hunchback just remake King Kong with a
whole new yeah higher state of living
this is a church tower and a giant
definitely Invisible Man he's Johnny
Depp you're gonna want to see him you
can't just hear him so I hope that most
of the film he is visible man and not
invisible because marketing matters
that's the thing man I hope Bride of
Frankenstein is Angelina Jolie and that
she's sexy and not scary yeah sexy and
powerful
yeah
and I hope Dracula's a strong hard pg-13
vampire would just like like it this is
the weirdest universe I had to
comprehend in a long time because
especially in the lead-up to the mummy
they have thrown out so many different
concepts in so many different ideas so
many different takes like so many
different versions of their own take on
what this is supposed to be so yeah like
I think I'm just kind of clenching right
now reading them thinking boy it could
work but I just feel like it's a very
taller I mean I'd love to see this like
reading this quote I love the only one
who should not what I want to sing now
yeah so on our extended movie news
segment on the patreon we were covering
you know Blanc and this article this
interview did about chappie but we want
to put on the YouTube as well Neill
Blomkamp actor from something Twitter us
Steven Blomkamp said at his brother I
love these guys his faces I'm assuming
yeah course his father nice person I
love these guys faces while they watch
her trailer and it was our studio
reaction Neill Blomkamp it haha awesome
at the real rejects and yay yeah is
there's a little photo covered you guys
it's kind of a cool moment I don't I
reject nation thanks for tuning in to
our weekly movie news of the week
segment we give you the top stories of
the things that we saw were the top of
the week not what other people think our
top these are our top chapping yeah when
it's not in this one anyway you can
subscribe to the real rejects Court that
notification bail - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house calm and you can
check out our full movie news segment
and I like the 45 or whatever how long
it is version 6 to 8 business edition of
of the movie news on top of that a bunch
of exclusive perks and content on our
patreon go over there check it out have
a great day and I'm not a gamer
I know a lot of you are going to be
sending in game requests and then when I
honor the request there will be plenty
of comments going why are you reacting
to this if you're not a gamer what the
hell's our deal well I'm doing it cuz
people laugh and it's a benefit of
creative crossroads in my life between
comments and you guys and me but hey
let's see what happens